and she went into her own version of the
scene you only have one chance to
impress the filmmakers and these actors
took it improvisation is common in
movies but it can also be found in the
casting process which actors were
confident enough to go off script for
the role they wanted i lied to martin
scorsese for hugo tom holland's
performance as spider-man in the mcu is
beloved by fans and a lot of people
can't imagine anyone else in the role
tom made sure no other actor had a
chance to get the part by nailing his
auditions he did a scene opposite robert
downey jr and the two improvised
together riffing off each other i'm
ready i'm ready
okay yeah i love invention this is
despite tom's agents warning him not to
improvise at all turns out it was the
best thing to do as they loved tom's
natural charisma and cast him as the
webslinger do i need to do that i know
we're on different teams i just don't
want to be disrespectful to you the
guardian of the galaxy landed the role
of star-lord by impressing james gunn
during an audition alongside dave
bautista pratt improvised his response
to bautista asking why he would put his
finger on his throat that's just a an
expression for slicing he also
improvised his line after he touched
bautista on the shoulder i won't touch
you again that's the last time i touch
you gunn actually resisted auditioning
pratt but after seeing him perform this
scene he knew he was the guy for the
role robert downey jr has a natural
charisma to him which can't be
replicated so it's no surprise he went
off script for his audition to become
the now iconic iron man he has said
multiple times in the past that he
regularly disregards what is written as
he prefers going off book at one part
during his audition his improv led him
to offer some vegetable snacks to the
person working with him in the scene
supporting downey's love of snacking on
set
crudite
we would see his natural ability to
improvise make its way into the movies
as he became the character of tony stark
blooper daker montgomery plays the
intimidating billy hargrove in stranger
things and it's hard to imagine anyone
else in the role montgomery decided not
to wear a shirt for a good portion of
his audition which was completely his
choice he also decided to improvise a
little dance to the song come on eileen
that showcased his ability to be
intimidating scary and funny all at the
same time he truly embodied the troubled
character you are dead kid khal drogo is
one intimidating dude on game of thrones
so the role had to go to someone just as
intimidating jason momoa ended up being
the perfect match and he landed the role
thanks to a bold decision to start his
audition off with an improvised haka
dance it's a traditional dance
originally created by different mari
tribes in new zealand it was a great
decision that helped mamoa secure the
role
daphne keane was only 11 years old when
she appeared in logan it was a big role
and a crucial one for the film as the
character appeared alongside hugh
jackman in his last turn as wolverine
during an audition when she read
alongside jackman she improvised an
entire scene with the veteran actor
speaking in both english and spanish
[Music]
which was completely her idea everyone
was blown away by her performance and
the scene even made it into the movie
the great patrick stewart stated it was
one of the most extraordinary audition
tapes he had ever seen thank you
you know and love the golden trio of
rupert grint daniel radcliffe and emma
watson but have you ever thought about
the other actors that auditioned for
these legendary roles well there were
quite a few
thousands of children going for first
year roles auditioned during the open
casting calls if they were called back
they had to improvise a scene where they
are a student arriving at hogwarts
ultimately we know who ended up being
the best choices
not me not hermione you alden ehrenreich
was the first person to audition for
young han solo he ended up doing six
auditions mixing in some improv moments
that proved he had mastered the swagger
and charisma of harrison ford's iconic
character in one of his auditions he
acted alongside a dog puppet that he had
to interact with i got a really good
feeling about this john krasinski's
audition for jim halpert on the office
contain more talk about fruit than you
would probably think creator and
showrunner greg daniels asked krasinski
to do some improv about his favorite
fruit during his audition the comedic
actor started rambling on about
pomegranates discussing how he only gets
them once a year he even ended the
conversation with a classic gym look
right into the camera john was just the
absolute best bugs bunny at getting
those looks across
i'm boring myself just talking about
for the movie hugo director martin
scorsese was adamant about only casting
britons for the film chloe grace moretz
who is american wasn't going to let that
stop her she decided to audition and do
so with a british accent lying to
everyone there claiming she was british
when the audition was over moretz
thanked the director in her regular
american accent which shocked scorsese
he was impressed enough with her however
to break his rule and cast her as
isabelle wait a second kid you're you're
american i was like i am he was like you
fooled me steve carell is now known as a
legendary comedic actor but at the
beginning of his career he had to prove
his talents in each and every audition
for his audition for the role brick
tamlin in anchorman carell dazzled the
casting department with his masterful
improv in the scene carell was
pretending to eat a rancid sandwich with
will ferrell also performing in the
scene his exaggerated eating and
movements had the panel dying of
laughter and he laughed along with them
which fit perfectly with his character
for forrest gump tom hanks did an
audition in tandem with hayley joel
osmond who would go on to play forrest
gump's son in the movie hanks improvised
a lot of his dialogue during the scene
mostly to help osmond and make him feel
comfortable he talked about cartoons and
even made sure osman kept his eyes up to
the camera through hank's implicit
kindness he showed exactly what was
needed to portray the kind-hearted gump
you watch cartoons yeah what's your
favorite did you know that most of the
blair witch project was completely
improvised improvising for an entire
movie meant finding the perfect cast to
do so actress heather donahue recalled
the auditioning process which she found
through an ad that included the line it
is going to be hell and most of you
reading this probably shouldn't come at
the audition actors were immediately hit
with a prompt to improvise as a
character that has been in jail for nine
years and if they hesitated for even a
moment the audition would end it's just
the three of us actors pretty much
making the movie during his audition for
forgetting sarah marshall russell brand
improvised an entire scene where he had
to passive-aggressively convince his
partner to go horseback riding it's a
hilarious scene that demonstrates bran's
comedic chops he had everyone in the
room laughing and there was no better
man for the part first time i met you if
i'd mentioned allspec riding you'd have
chomped at the bit more than any horse
would jim carrey is known for his
over-the-top outrageous comedy bits so
when he auditioned to play andy kaufman
in man on the moon he wasn't seen as a
legit contender that was until he
absolutely nailed his audition the tape
he sent in was completely improvised and
it sold the creators of the film that
carrie was perfect for the part
[Music]
it takes a lot of confidence to go off
script and improvise during an audition
it could have made the difference
between these actors landing the part
and us seeing a completely different
actor portraying our favorite characters
today which actor do you think had the
most impressive improvisation